so not so inconvenient
grandmaster britney supposedly has oki from
switzerland although that could well
be someone who is playing in biel right now
and is sitting in the gran hotel room so
this variant if he has something
unusual shape
black someone missed a film
so you can now take any
direct measures here  initiate
I'm always trying to take the
direct route to the goal
there because I now think it
doesn't work at all
the 2 I can only hit f6 first
so that although now again 25 next to the
package doesn't really have to play knight
five or is us or
so the 5 is deeply unfair if he
goes yes yes he says it goes like this runs 4
maybe that's how I really don't have
to pull the none then only for the five
runners e2 if you maybe we can do
that
I'd really like him to
pull away from the knights
i have less time
to play lighter skater he wins doubt i
have to stop
there actually then play  t
so brings it really very risky
black i think it looks looks very
dangerous so maybe even jumper
g5 directly gold doesn't matter
he has everything else birds standing around
seven gymnastics club to say how back
there somewhere maybe
the four are good so the 4
there you can  play directly here
somehow so directly damar 5 can also
be considered back
then
i think the muslims do so that
's true now definitely won for
rice everything else would really
surprise me so maybe we can
take h7 now had seven then
seven so the five  king so
at least a perpetual chess
bishop g5 or with that g7 still with the
between matt
paul berning
now and others looking for hirt homer
four maybe then we'll do
a satan dhabi 1 he tells me strong
computer yeah i can't do anything
if you all  figures to show films
centimeters until stop makes